Pourquoi est-ce que les chocs permanents actuels
ne nous poussent pas à agir ?
Pourquoi ne créent-ils pas d'avancées ?
Surtout quand il s'agit du changement climatique.
Je veux vous parler aujourd'hui
de ce que je pense être une recette plus complète
pour une transformation profonde
déclenchée par des événements choquants.
Je vais me concentrer sur deux ingrédients clés,
souvent omis des livres d'histoire.
L'un concerne l'imagination, l'autre, l'organisation.
Car c'est dans l'interaction entre les deux
que se trouve le pouvoir révolutionnaire.
Commençons par l'imagination.
Les victoires du New Deal ne se sont pas produites car soudainement
tout le monde comprenait la brutalité du laissez-faire.
C'était une époque, souvenez-vous, de considérable effervescence idéologique,
beaucoup d'idées différentes sur l'organisation des sociétés
s'affrontaient dans le débat public.
Une époque où l'humanité osait avoir de grands rêves
pour différents types de futurs,
nombre d'entre eux organisés selon des axes radicalement égalitaires.
Ces idées n'étaient pas toutes bonnes,
mais c'était une époque d'imagination explosive.
Cela signifiait que les mouvements réclamant un changement
savaient à quoi ils s'opposaient --
une pauvreté écrasante, des inégalités grandissantes --
mais, tout aussi important, ils savaient ce qu'ils soutenaient.
Ils avaient leurs « non » et également leurs « oui ».
Ils avaient des modèles d'organisation politique très différents
de ceux d'aujourd'hui.
Durant des années, les mouvements sociaux et ouvriers
avaient établi la composition de leurs membres,
reliant leurs causes entre elles et se renforçant.
Ce qui signifie qu'au moment du krach de 1929,
il y avait déjà un mouvement, assez large et étendu
pour, par exemple, organiser des grèves qui arrêtaient non seulement des usines,
mais aussi des villes entières.
Les grandes victoires politiques du New Deal
étaient en fait proposées comme des compromis.
Car l'alternative semblait être la révolution.
Ajustons l'équation évoquée plus tôt.
Un événement choquant plus une imagination utopique,
plus la force d'un mouvement,
c'est ainsi qu'on obtient une vraie avancée.
Notre époque est-elle à la hauteur ?
Nous vivons, à nouveau, une période d'engagements politiques extraordinaires.
La politique est une obsession populaire.
Des mouvements progressistes grandissent et résistent avec un courage formidable.
Pourtant, l'Histoire nous rappelle que dire « non » ne suffit pas.
Quelques « oui » émergent.
Ils deviennent bien plus courageux très rapidement.
Les activistes du changement climatique parlaient de changer les ampoules,
maintenant nous insistons pour que 100% de notre énergie
vienne du soleil, du vent et des vagues,
et que l'on agisse vite.
Les mouvements déclenchés par la violence policière contre les Afro-américains
demandent la fin de la police militarisée,
de l'incarcération de masse
et même des réparations pour l'esclavage.
Les étudiants ne s'opposent plus à l'augmentation des frais de scolarité,
mais du Chili au Canada en passant par le Royaume-Uni,
ils réclament une scolarité gratuite et l'annulation des dettes étudiantes.
Pourtant, cela n'atteint pas
le genre de vision holistique et universaliste
d'un monde différent que nos prédécesseurs avaient.
Pourquoi ?
Très souvent, de nos jours, nous voyons le changement politique
dans des sous-catégories définies.
L'environnement dans une boîte, l'inégalité dans une autre,
l'égalité raciale et de genre dans deux autres boîtes,
l'éducation par ci, la santé par là.
Dans chaque sous-catégorie,
il y a des milliers et des milliers de groupes et d'ONG différentes,
tous en compétition les uns contre les autres pour la réputation, la notoriété
et, bien sûr, pour des ressources.
En d'autres mots, nous agissons beaucoup comme des entreprises.
On fait souvent référence à cela comme le problème des silos.
Les silos sont compréhensibles.
Ils divisent notre monde complexe en morceaux gérables.
Ils nous aident à nous sentir moins débordés.
Mais au passage, ils entraînent également notre cerveau à se déconnecter
quand le problème de quelqu'un d'autre est évoqué
et quand le problème de quelqu'un d'autre requiert notre aide et notre soutien.
Ils nous empêchent de voir des liens évidents entre nos problèmes.
Par exemple, les gens se battant contre la pauvreté et l'inégalité
parlent peu de changement climatique.
Même si nous avons vu à maintes reprises
que les gens les plus pauvres
sont les plus vulnérables aux catastrophes météorologiques.
Les activistes du changement climatique parlent peu de guerre et d'occupation.
Même si nous savons que la soif d'énergies fossiles
a été un facteur majeur dans les conflits.
Le mouvement environnemental dénonce de mieux en mieux
le fait que les nations les plus touchées par le changement climatique
sont généralement peuplées de personnes à la peau noire ou marron.
Mais quand les vies des Noirs sont aussi peu considérées
dans les prisons, les écoles et la rue,
ces rapprochements ne sont faits que trop rarement.
Les murs entre nos silos
font aussi que nos solutions, quand elles émergent,
sont également déconnectées les unes des autres.
Les progressistes ont cette longue liste de réclamations mentionnée plus tôt,
ces « oui ».
Mais il nous manque encore
une image cohérente du monde pour lequel nous nous battons.
Ce à quoi il ressemble, son atmosphère et, surtout, ses valeurs fondamentales.
Cela compte vraiment.
Car quand des crises à grande échelle nous frappent
et qu'il nous faut avancer vers une situation plus sûre,
il n'y a pas d'accord sur ce qu'est cette situation.
Avancer sans destination,
c'est un peu comme sautiller sur place.
(Rires)
Heureusement, il y a tout type de conversations et d'expériences en cours
afin d'essayer de dépasser ces divisions qui nous retiennent.
Pour finir, je veux parler de l'une d'entre elles.
Il y a deux ans, au Canada, certains d'entre nous
ont décidé que nous avions atteint les limites
de ce qui pouvait être accompli dans nos divers silos.
Nous nous sommes enfermés dans une pièce durant deux jours
et nous avons cherché à déterminer ce qui nous unissait.
Dans cette pièce, il y avait des gens qui sont rarement face à face.
Il y avait des sages indigènes
et des hipsters travaillant dans les transports.
Il y avait le directeur de Greenpeace
et un dirigeant syndical représentant les travailleurs du pétrole
et les bûcherons.
Il y avait des leaders religieux, des icônes féministes et bien d'autres.
Nous nous sommes donné une mission assez ambitieuse :
nous mettre d'accord sur une déclaration courte
décrivant le monde après notre victoire.
Le monde après avoir réalisé la transition vers une économie propre
et une société bien plus juste.
En d'autres mots,
au lieu d'essayer d'effrayer les gens
avec ce qui arrivera si nous n'agissons pas,
nous avons décidé d'essayer de les inspirer
en leur disant ce qu'il pourrait arriver si nous agissons.
Les gens sensés nous disent toujours
que le changement doit arriver par petites touches.
Que la politique est l'art du possible
et que nous ne pouvons pas laisser le mieux être l'ennemi du bien.
Nous avons rejeté tout cela.
Nous avons rédigé un manifeste intitulé « Un bond vers l'avant ».
Je dois vous dire que nous mettre d'accord sur notre « oui » commun
au sein d'une telle diversité d'expériences
et, avec en toile de fond, beaucoup d'histoires très douloureuses
ne fut pas un travail facile.
C'était assez passionnant.
Car dès que nous nous sommes donné la permission de rêver,
les fils qui relient la majorité de notre travail sont devenus évidents.
Nous avons par exemple réalisé
que la quête éperdue du profit
qui force tant de gens à travailler plus de 50 heures par semaine,
sans aucune sécurité d'emploi,
et qui alimente cette épidémie de désespoir
est la même recherche sans fin du profit et de la croissance
qui est au cœur de la crise écologique
et qui déstabilise notre planète.
Ce que nous devons faire est également devenu clair.
Nous devons créer une culture du soin.
Où personne n'est rejeté de nulle part.
Où la valeur inhérente à tout le monde
et à tous les écosystèmes est fondamentale.
Nous avons eu l'idée de cette plateforme,
ne vous inquiétez pas, je ne vais pas tout vous lire à voix haute --
si cela vous intéresse, vous pouvez le lire sur theleap.org.
Mais je vais vous donnez un avant-goût de ce que nous avons élaboré.
Nous demandons d'atteindre les 100% d'énergies renouvelables rapidement,
mais nous sommes allés plus loin.
Nous demandons de nouveaux accords commerciaux,
un débat solide sur le revenu universel,
sur les droits des travailleurs immigrés,
pour diminuer le financement privé en politique,
sur des soins gratuits universels, sur une réforme électorale et bien plus.
Nous avons découvert que beaucoup d'entre nous
demandent l'autorisation d'agir moins comme des entreprises
que comme des mouvements.
Car les mouvements se fichent de la renommée.
Ils veulent que les bonnes idées se répandent largement.
Ce que j'aime avec The Leap,
c'est qu'il rejette l'idée de cette hiérarchie de crises
et ne demande à personne de faire passer un combat avant un autre
ou d'attendre son tour.
S'il est né au Canada,
nous avons découvert qu'il voyage bien.
Depuis le lancement, The Leap s'est répandu à travers le monde
avec des plateformes similaires
rédigées du Nunavut à l'Australie
en passant par la Norvège, le Royaume-Uni et les États-Unis,
où il gagne beaucoup d'ampleur dans des villes comme Los Angeles,
où il se situe.
Ainsi que dans des communautés rurales traditionnellement très conservatrices
où la politique a déçu la majorité des gens.
Voilà ce que j'ai appris de l'étude des chocs et catastrophes durant 20 ans.
Les crises nous mettent à l'épreuve.
Soit nous nous effondrons, soit nous grandissons rapidement.
En trouvant des réserves de force et des capacités que nous ignorions avoir.
Les événements choquants qui nous remplissent aujourd'hui de peur
peuvent nous transformer et changer positivement le monde.
Mais nous devons d'abord imaginer le monde pour lequel nous nous battons.
Nous devons le rêver ensemble.
Toutes les alarmes de notre maison se déclenchent en même temps.
Il est temps d'écouter.
Il est temps d'avancer.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)